mein freund mästet mich teil 6 hey leute
was die herzlich willkommen beim neuen
video
heute bin ich mal in der anmoderation
und es geht um seven eleven kennt ihr
diesen laden ich kannte ja viel für mich
und ich weiß auch gar nicht was alles
fort also übergebe ich jetzt mal an alex
einmal noch was bloß weil man noch mehr
tun
hey leute was geht herzlich willkommen
beim neuen video
heute geht es bei alex video und emily
level ich weiß wir den laden kennt ich
kenne auf jeden fall nicht und ich weiß
auch nicht genau was alex ward
also machen wir mal was also was willst
du denn jetzt machen wenn also alexa
produkte kauft ich verstehe ja zurück
und ich wollte einfach mal was draußen
glaubt heute was geht maria schon super
an dieser stelle wirklich glaube du
solltest du mal überdenken ich auch eine
fette youtube karriere zu starten dann
spaß heute ich habe natürlich euch jetzt
gut ich bin gerade zusammen mit marie
haben uns gelungen und wir sind gerade
zusammen im winterurlaub wenn man das so
nennen kann also der tag eigentlich
geplanten den schnee zu fahren aktuell
sind wir in ich verrate einfach mal
nicht weil sonst macht das nächste video
was irgendwann kommt keinen sinn weil
sie das jetzt unbedingt rauskriegen
wollte schon ein provinzler und aber
hier verrate ich noch nicht leute das
hier wird kein mega aufwendiges video
ist auch nicht möglich weil ich halt
einfach wohl in der kamera dabei habe
und keine ahnung was es heißt wie warum
dass sie aber es wird ein sehr
spannendes video und zwar geht es heute
wieder grad schon gesagt wurde im anfang
um zellen eleven
das hier ist sie lassen das gibt es
überall auf der welt wirklich also
gefügt überall auf der welt außer in
deutschland österreich und schweiz da
gibt es nicht das ist auch kein werbe
videos oder so ich habe mich nur raten
informiert sam eleven kommt aus japan
glaub ich irgendwo asiatisch und die
haben einfach mehr filialen als
mcdonald's also diesen auf platz eins
der welt die gibt es wie gesagt überall
ausser bei uns und ich habe das
das schon so oft gesehen egal ob ich
jetzt in dänemark war ob ich in amerika
war ob ich jetzt hier bin
überall gibt es diese leben also diesem
weg ihr an jeder ecke und es gibt auch
schon eine menge youtube videos dazu
allerdings noch kein einziges deutsches
ich hab mal nachgeguckt und ich habe
keins gefunden wenn ihr uns kennt dann
seid ihr mir da voraus aber gut an idee
kein plan haben was das eigentlich ist
ich würde jetzt einfach mal als coolen
kinos beschreiben also da kann man
einiges kaufen ich habe in dem laden mal
kurz mit meinem handy gefilmt kann ich
euch ja hier mal ein rennen also das ist
so ja wie so ein chaos da gibt es
getränke
da gibt es süßigkeiten da gibt es aber
auch viele warme speisen jeder einfach
schnell fertig machen und ich finde das
konzept echt cool und wir probieren
einfach mal so ein paar sachen ich habe
auch rausgekriegt das ist natürlich von
land zu land noch mal ein bisschen
unterschiedlich ist in asien gibt zum
beispiel da auch so fertig nudeln und
sowas da kannst du ganz in nudeln sachen
die schnell bestellen also
zusammengefasst könnte man es so als
luxus kios vielleicht beschreiben also
da gibt es sehr viele sachen einfach
direkt schnell zum mitnehmen und ich hab
mal ein paar eingekauft und und ich
würde sagen die probieren wir mal
schnell zusammen ihr könnt ja gern jetzt
meine kommentare schreiben kennt ihr
diese kette ja oder nein einfach mal ja
oder nein schreiben nein du kannst dich
auch nicht bis vor einem jahr ungefähr
kannst du auch wenn die tendenz geholt
haben wir zum beispiel ein genau calzone
pizza das hier ist eine waffe da ich
euch gleich mal es gibt es viele
joghurts die man halt einfach so
mitnehmen kann
das haben nach dem möbel minima gemacht
dann habe ich einfach mal noch irgendwas
norwegisches mitgenommen richtigkeit
keine ahnung vielleicht woanders her und
was ich jetzt irgendwie gar nicht so
rein fand aber was hier der absolute
renner sein sollten
das hat irgendwann ganz genau das ist
irgendwie so ein würstchen wenn ich das
jetzt so sehe war schon schlecht
eigentlich aber ich hab's einfach
mitgenommen was man sagen muss dass hier
extrem teuer dafür alles zusammen
umgerechnet 20 euro bezahlt ja muss man
schon mal schlucken
ich muss sagen wir fangen einfach mal an
die mit der zeitzone bin ich mega geil
kannst dich einfach mitnehmen
in deutschland habe ich so etwas noch
nie gesehen dass man das nicht am kiosk
kaufen und dass deswegen fühlt sich in
steinhardt ganz locker das ding ist
diese sachen wenn dann mal kurz
aufgewärmt würden dann gegeben wenn man
gerade eine kleine pause gemacht
deswegen ist es so kalt keine ahnung
aber weiter und so könnten china noch
mal gesehen
fünf euro kostet das ist haben wir jetzt
noch irgendwie so ein joghurtbecher aus
schönstes und hardware award an ich
hoffe breit probieren war das nicht
meint das ist gar nicht mein schmeckt
ich merkte dass also bisher ist er seine
gemischte meinung ich weiß noch wo ich
lasse es mit freunden von mir in den
markt waren wir da immer uns ins netz
geholt da kann man sich auch so
pizzastücke schnell holen die waren
eigentlich echt lecker deswegen wenn ich
jetzt mal gespannt hier auf die waffe du
darfst die fetzen
hallo also da muss ich sagen wir schon
ausprobiert hast du schon weiß noch mal
macht die musik
hmm wirkung
manchmal lässt mich teil sechs kommen
eine kleine zucker posten ist doch noch
nie war ich würde also da muss ich jetzt
aufpassen dass wir nicht also dass ich
dir ganz normal dagegen in jedem slevin
diese würstchen vor dem schaufenster
die ist auch so echt übel zwar kalt aber
mache ich einmal probiert hmm lecker
trinken man kann übrigens in norwegen
überall aus wasserhahn trinken weil das
wasser so klar ist und schmeckt doch
echt gut also dass hier ist unser bades
noch leute ja ich halte es einfach mal
vor euch bei nächster gelegenheit mal
diesen laden zu zeigen weil das letzte
mal schon machen muss ist amerika
stellen und ich glaube deswegen jetzt
von mir ich weiß war kein besonderes
video ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
also wenn ihr den mal seht probiert er
meine ist es echt geil
zumindest wenn es kein bisschen ist oder
halt einfach mal rein zu gehen ist halt
so kommt etwas anderes wie wir es in
deutschland kennen wir nicht vergessen
daumen nach oben drückt auf instagram
art von wir sehen uns morgen oder
übermorgen wieder da gibt es den block
formiert weil das war also neue
überraschung eigentlich hier parteien
[Musik]